love is in the air behind me okay this
is a prized possession of pop culture
right here this is like the Queen like
you cannot hurt her I need a drink
for you guys or was it sort of like time
trust grew I feel like it was semi
insane right it was perfect timing he
took me out of my birthday and we stayed
in touch every day after and actually
tomorrow is like six months from the
birthday I feel like the only thing
missing is the alcohol in the record
tell me about this area of what it means
to have the MTV VMAs your home for your
show in Jersey
I mean think I New York is none of this
place is literally 20 minutes away from
my house say like alright I could go
crazy and like 12 and then movements
well there is nothing
yeah what do people need to know about
Jersey and like like the secrets Jersey
just amazing all around you have the
Jersey Shore in the summer we're here
like we're in our own room right now
it's so cool so chefs coming back we're
ready I mean I don't get good air on
Thursday so we're at season three right
now yes make sure you guys watch as I
get a clock on Jersey never leaving
first
we're never leaving yes what's it like
for you to be new to the clan it's
amazing they've all accepted me with
living rooms and they've really helped
me out with my team so I'm like really
appreciative of the minute for sure how
are you doing and how's he doing I'm
good I mean he's doing great he makes
sure I have a good positive outlook and
I just handle it like anything else one
day at a time
I can't look ahead too much otherwise
I'll trip over you know thinking about
so much of it so we're good
[Music]